In 1961, Yuri Gagarin became the first person
to go into space, opening a new chapter in
human exploration, and inspiring hundreds
of people around the world to follow in his
footsteps, some of them quite literally.
Legend goes, that Gagarin desperately had
to urinate before lift off, so he asked the
bus to stop and since they were in the middle
of a flat featureless landscape, he went against
the rear wheel.
That act is now immortalised as a pre-launch
ritual by cosmonaut crew members who take
it in turns to pee on the rear wheel of their
bus before the get on board.
We'd be right in calling ritualistic behaviour
irrational. After all, peeing on the rear
wheel of a bus ins't going to make space travel
any safer, so why do we do it? According to
psychologist Cristine Legare, it's a reflection
of the way the human brain works. And the
human brain is inherently irrational.
Our minds are always seeking out patterns,
even when they don't exist. Often seeking
out connections between cause and effect,
sometimes without any evidence of their truth.
With this in mind, rituals provide us with
the same satisfaction as everyday tasks that
have known positive effects like brushing
your teeth. And so in part rituals exist to
give us the illusion of control over our otherwise
random lives.
Gagarin plays a pivotal role in the traditions
carried out by modern cosmonauts. Since he
made his historic flight, all cosmonauts now
visit his office after their training to sign
his guestbook and ask his ghost permission
to go into space. But although this superstitious
behaviour seems irrational, scientists have
shown that there's evidence of real beneficial
effect.
A study on basketball players found that athletes
who performed pre-event rituals tend to report
lower levels of anxiety, and greater levels
of confidence. Another suggests that participating
in superstitious behaviour can improve motor
dexterity and memory. Research suggests that
the nature of the ritual determines how effective
it will be: the more complex and detailed
it is, the more convincing it becomes.
So for the Russians, the tradition of following
so firmly in the footsteps of Gagarin from
the training centre to the launch of the rocket
provides them with a powerful ritual that
prepares them for the lack of control they
feel over what might be the most dangerous
eight minutes of their lives.
Religion is a recent addition to space ritual.
In 1994 cosmonaut Aleksandr Viktorenko requested
a blessing from an orthodox priest before
his mission. And this has since become a pre-launch
ritual. Even NASA and ESA astronauts launching
from Baikonur receive an orthodox blessing,
and that includes Tim Peake.
Ritualistic behaviour brings people together,
providing social cohesion when there's little
or no intimacy to be had. And where could
that be more important than for a crew in
space? It cements the crew's relationship
with each other, it provides an all-important
link to Earth, and it provides them with a
sense of connection with their place in human
history.